[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 109 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Mach Mandel and I mean with my
colleague Melanie work how are you doing
today Melanie morning mark it's good to
see you
yeah bright and early bright and early
well just after MLK Day indeed we have
some great content this week you helped
organize and a really cool episode
talking about Auto ml with any Unruh and
Sarah Robinson right we are releasing
the cloud Auto ml vision this week and
so we wanted to get them on podcast
because they both have been working with
a application and they have some cool
examples that we're gonna put in our
show notes but before we get to the
interview as always we're going to talk
about the cool thing of the week and
stay tuned after where we're going to
ask the question if you are with an
educational institution how can you get
google cloud credits alright first cool
thing of the week Google brain actually
posted out a looking back on 2017 and
some really top of mind interests for
them and so Auto ml is actually one of
the subjects that's in their blog but
they also touch on things like speech
understanding and generation as well as
TP use and they give some great links to
different data sources that you can
explore for machine learning so it's a
it's a good blog post to check out and
see and how they saw 2017 nice mark you
got any other cool things of the week
yeah I'll interrupt your ml fest that's
good I'll bring it back to my two of my
passions actually so there's a new
solution that's coming out about running
dedicated game servers after multiplayer
games in kubernetes engine I know many
people have probably seen my blog post
series talking about doing the very
similar thing but there's now an
official solution that has been released
there's a blog post we'll link in the
show notes and the solution itself
talking specifically about how you can
do this on kubernetes engine on Google
cloud platform so if you're building
multiplayer games and work in the games
industry go for look nice and then the
other cool thing of the week that we
wanted to mention is that Kaggle has
launched their data science education
resources and tools and I guess just
actual program that's on their site
we'll have a link on our site as well as
always but this is being headed up by
Dan Becker and Rachel Chapman
and they are covering subjects like
machine learning data visualization and
deep learning and they're focusing most
of the course content in Python so you
should check that out a couple other
honorable mentions because we couldn't
resist we heard about apparently you
know they've done all this research in
terms of trying to map neurons in the
brain a couple years back now or I guess
I'm not sure I should say how long ago
they were able to accomplish this with
the worm well apparently recently
scientists were able to take what
they've mapped and put it into a LEGO
robots so whole foot a link to that it's
kind of it's got a video and everything
associated to it it's really weird I'm
watching this video of the thing and
like I know it's kind of fun and then
the other thing I meant to mention with
the Google brain look back they actually
referenced Kaz Sato who's one of our
colleagues he did a rock-paper-scissors
example with tensorflow and I him and
his son apparently put this together and
they actually have some video about how
they make it work which is kind of fun
so they play against this tool that they
built very cool so we'll listen that as
well awesome sounds good so now let's go
talk to Amy and Sarah let's do that this
week's podcast we are joined by two of
our colleagues Sarah Robinson and Amy
Unruh who are our developer relations
engineers hi good morning my name so can
y'all tell us a little bit more about
yourselves and what you do sure Amy you
want to start sure yeah so I developer
relations engineer for the Google cloud
platform and I have a background in AI
and machine learning and focusing on
those areas right now in previous lives
I've worked for first startups and done
industrial Rd and even written a book
about app engine nice great Sarah
awesome I'm on the same team at as Amy
we're focused on big data and machine
learning I come from more of a
self-taught background and before I was
on the cloud team I was a developer
relations engineer on the firebase team
at Google great
so the reason why we have both of you
here today is because today we are
releasing cloud Auto ml vision and we
wanted you both to help share a little
bit more about what that's about so can
you tell us what
is first I will talk a little bit about
the products that we currently have if
you want to do image recognition on
Google cloud platform so right now your
options are to use the vision API which
is a pre trained model and it gives you
access to this model with just one REST
API requests so you can send your image
to the API you get back a bunch of data
on what it thinks it's a picture of if
you want to do something more custom so
the vision API doesn't require any
training data of your own if you have
some a problem that's more specific to
your use case you can build and train a
custom model a tensorflow
and use your own training data to train
and tune the model but there's kind of
been a gap in our current product
offerings I mean that's why we're really
excited about cloud auto ml vision so
what cloud auto ml vision lets you do is
it lets developers that don't have too
much machine learning expertise to build
high quality models so the way it works
is you upload your images they can be
either labeled or unlabeled data set to
the cloud auto ml vision UI you just
press a button to train your model and
then you can access your model with an
easy-to-use
REST API so under the hood it's using
both state-of-the-art transfer learning
and something called neural architecture
search transfer learning essentially
what that is is you leverage an already
trained model it's already trained
weights and it turns out that the so
called embeddings that better learned
you know it's part of the process of
training this model incorporate really
useful abstractions related to image
classification that transfer to things
that the original model wasn't actually
trained on so you can essentially take
an already trained model and tap into it
at the so-called bottleneck layer you
know a layer of embedding sort of just
before the output of the model and use
that to bootstrap training of new image
classifications so you can take a neural
net that's you know trained on a bunch
of things like you know different
animals and boats and cars and things
like that and you can train it on a new
data set your own data new
classifications very successfully
without eating very much data so that's
transfer learning so with our previous
cloud vision API
we people were able to use it for
problems but a lot of times their image
analysis but they were limited to what's
provided in that cloud vision API there
wasn't as much flexibility for their
specific datasets is that when I'm
understanding yeah that's correct so the
vision API has a fixed set of categories
that it recognizes a very large number
of categories but there's still fixed
categories so so if you're if you're in
a specialized domain it's not going to
distinguish your own domain specific
categories the the way that you would
like to I was gonna ask what sort of
categories would you be talking about
then that you think or don't quite
specialized what does that mean well one
really good example one of the early
customers is using Auto ml vision to try
to do specialized training of large
number of different wildlife categories
so this is something that auto ml vision
is not going to be able to detect with
the right level of specificity another
possible example is let's say you work
in the manufacturing industry and you've
got very specific parts that you're
using on some sort of assembly line and
you want to determine whether there's a
faulty part in some sort of the process
so likely you have a lot of training
data images of different parts of this
assembly line you could train a custom
model to identify a broken part and
that's what the auto ml vision that's
been released as of today yeah so when
we would speak about the vision API
before the first question we would
always get is how can I make this more
customized until today we didn't have an
answer for that so that's why we're
we're super excited about Auto ml vision
so Sarah you said something a little
earlier that I actually wanted to come
back to you said that people could
provide both labeled and unlabeled
images like I can get what happens with
labeled images right so there's pre chip
but if I hand somebody unlabeled images
how does that work doesn't somebody have
to provide the data about what something
is yeah so this is pretty cool one
feature of auto ml vision is that you
can have a team of in-house human
labelers that will review your
instructions and they'll classify your
images for you so often people have
already labeled their datasets but there
are some cases where you might just have
a bunch of images that are unlabeled so
the way this works is you provide a few
instructions
so for the image categories that you're
hoping the labelers will use to label
your images you can provide a few what
they call exemplar images to say this is
a really good example of whatever
specific label you're trying to provide
and the human labelers will work on
labeling your images accordingly and
then you'll get a set of labeled images
back that you can feed into Auto ml
vision for trainings oh so there's human
laborers who can help with this and auto
ml vision also has a nice UI it'll
detect if you give it a data set not all
of the images and the data set have to
be already labeled and it'll identify
the ones for you that aren't labeled and
has a nice UI that that lets you label
them interactively if there aren't you
know a huge number of them kind of
touching further on this label and we
were talking a little bit about this
before how is this different between
Auto ml vision and the original cloud
vision API for labeling cloud vision API
only exposes the the prediction aspect
it doesn't let you provide your own
labels at all you give it image isn't it
it tells you the classifications that
it's detected but you cannot tune it
with with your own images and your own
labels it's just curious this off the
developer point of view how does that
look is there like a special API I need
to push my images to do I push it to
like Google Cloud storage what's that
flow look like are you talking about
generating the predictions yeah so like
I want to provide my own images and do
my own labels how do I get that in yeah
there's a couple different ways to do
that so first if you want to try out
your model right away once it's been
trained you can actually just upload
images for prediction in the UI and see
what predictions you get back but then
obviously after you do that you'll want
to build an app that probably queries
your newly trained model and to do that
you can either use the cloud ml engine
prediction API or you can use the cloud
vision API so if you're already using
the vision API in production and let's
say you want to switch you have a lot of
training data you want to train a model
on auto ml you actually just have to
make a few small updates to the way your
vision API request looks so instead of
label detection you would use custom
model detection and then you pass it the
ID of the model that you just trained
and you're good to go
generating predictions with the vision
API suite and if I have a whole bunch of
data I want to upload I'm guessing I'm
not gonna do that through the UI there's
some sort of automated
I blame for that for training yeah yeah
so you can either upload images locally
from your computer or you can put all of
your images in Google Cloud storage and
then create a CSV file with the URL of
your image and the Associated label if
you have one and if I have any new
images after I've got a trained model
what would that look like for this you
could iteratively add new images to your
data set so that works well and then you
can just retrain once you've added the
new images great and then you're saying
it's a graphical user interface that's
going to be provided basically on the
GCP website in the same area as they can
find the other api's currently it's it's
a little more stand-alone in terms of
the URL okay but it's a very nice UI
that lets you and inspect valuation
results run online predictions the whole
deal eventually it'll be part of the
cloud console but the alpha version as
Amy mentioned is a separate UI okay cool
so you say something else in passing too
and I think it's probably worth going a
little deeper on what you're talking
about once you've got a trained model
that works in club vision API you're
able to access it through the cloud
vision API which is really cool but the
second thing you said was you're also
able to export it through the cloud ml
engine can you just talk a bit about
what that product is and how that would
work for people who aren't familiar with
Cloud ml engine sure yeah cloud ml
engine is a product that we provide that
lets you build your own custom
tensorflow model and then you can use ml
engine to run your model training in the
cloud and also to deploy your model for
serving and this is actually what auto
ml vision is using under the hood and so
if you're already using cloud ml engine
and you're more comfortable with that
API for generating predictions and this
is just another way that you can
generate predictions with oto mo all
right Amy you were touching before on
the neural architecture search
technology there was some blog post that
was released in November around some of
the work that was done analysis to scale
that can you tell us a little bit more
about what that is and how that's used
yeah so we'll point to some links in the
show notes was typically meant by neural
architecture search is performing some
type of neural net based search of
neural net architectures that are useful
for a particular task and there are
different variants of this for example
there's
evolutionary approach and there's a
reinforcement learning based approach
and one type of neural architects our
search framework there's something
called a controller part of the
framework it's a recurrent neural net
and what it does is it it samples child
networks with different architectures
tries out different architectures and
then the accuracy of a given child
network is used to update the controller
for its next round of architecture
generation one key insight is that for
image classification problems for
example you often use convolutional
neural nets they often have repeated
motifs like for example different
combinations of convolutional filter
banks and so sort of a key observation
then is that you can build interesting
new architectures in your search space
of new architectures by stacking up
these motifs these different pieces of
the neural net so that's technology
behind what we're using here auto ml is
leveraging the results of some of this
neural architecture search technology in
a particular kind of leveraging this
ability to explore the search space by
kind of stacking up generic cells so
it's very interesting stuff and again
we'll put some links in the show notes
and that's great and my understanding
too is that the nice thing is that this
type of approach is allowing us to then
do auto ml you know not require the
people who are using the tool to really
have a PhD in ml to have to know and be
an expert in terms of building models
and and tuning models exactly yeah
that's the whole intent behind it and in
fact perhaps we should have mentioned
this earlier when we're talking about
transfer learning those who are more
familiar with neural nets might have
tried for example to do transfer
learning examples using tensor flow and
so if you've tried that you'll know that
you know it takes a little bit of coding
and you have to kind of figure out how
to plug things into each other so with
Auto Amell vision there's none of that
you don't need to do any coding yourself
or figure out any of that but you're
leveraging state-of-the-art approach
kind of in the same manner great in
terms of auto ml we've been talking
about it as cloud auto ml vision it's
focused on vision is there
tenth or what's the future look like for
this yeah so this is just the first of
the auto ml products we can't talk in
too much detail about what's coming next
I know it's bummer there are teams that
are actively working on other products
under this auto ml umbrella to
accomplish other common machine learning
tasks like we already provide in our
cloud ml api's so more is coming I mean
it's this tool in particular is playing
into this whole AI democratizing ml is
trying to make things easier for people
to apply ml to their products and
services yeah definitely so if you're
coming from an app developer background
and you don't have any machine learning
experience this tool provides a really
easy to use UI for you to be able to
train a custom model and then just use
one API call to generate predictions
against it so part of the reason why we
got the two of you together was also
because you guys have been doing some
demos around this did you want to speak
a little bit to what kind of demos and
what it's been like using the API so
yeah it's been great to be able to try
out this product and provide feedback
before the launch and one demo that I
worked on is I compiled a data set of
cloud photos because I thought it would
be cool and kind of funny if I use the
cloud to recognize clouds yes so what I
didn't know before I started doing this
is that there's over ten different types
of clouds and they all only ten yeah I
would have expected more there's
definitely more there's like 10 high
level types I was gonna say I thought
clouds are like snowflakes go ahead yeah
if there's any meteorologist listening
they'll probably say that there's way
way more than 10 but I it down to 10
categories and all of these different
types of clouds obviously reveal
different things about upcoming weather
patterns so you can use images of clouds
to predict weather patterns so I wanted
to see if I could build a model that was
able to detect different cloud types
while doing some research on this I
tried out the vision API so I got a
couple different types of cloud images
sent them to the existing vision API the
vision API was able to identify them as
clouds obviously but it didn't really
get more specific than that which is
fine they wouldn't expect it to be able
to recognize different types of clouds
so what I did is I gathered training
data I got a bunch of different images
of all of these 10 types and
I used that to train a model with Auto
ml and it ended up working very well so
now I'm able to feed an image of a cloud
to the model and it can tell me what
type of cloud it is and using that I can
predict me what type of weather is
coming and actually to do this I worked
with a meteorologist at Google name is
Rob Carver who's a huge help in making
sure that I label these images correctly
obviously I'm not a domain expert in
identifying types of clouds so he was
able to help both in finding photos and
labeling them correctly so that was a
huge help great and Amy what about your
demo so I've been experimenting with a
data set of coastline images taken by
drones and this is a data set courtesy
of Texas A&M that they were nice enough
to make public so I will will release it
in the show notes so this is a data set
full of images labeled with all sorts of
esoteric labels things like exposed
riprap structures and whatever those are
sheltered scarps I don't know what that
is either
salt brackish water marches images
labeled like that and and so I'm
experimenting with how well can I use
auto ml to to be able to correctly label
new such images and I should add
something we haven't really talked very
much about the auto ml UI has a really
nice interface for inspecting what kind
of results you got from your training
things like area under the curve
precision recall metrics the so-called
confusion matrix that lets you see how
well your prediction did for each labels
so this this has been really helpful as
I've been experimenting with this and
I'm finding that some of these different
coastline types are predicted really
easily and some not so easily and that
would be you know an indication maybe of
where you wanted to find more data and
retrain your model so it's been really
fun to play with again we'll put in the
show notes links to this so you can
experiment with it yourself if you want
to so basically like to sort of hit home
that point some more like even if I
don't have a PhD in machine learning I
can still work out like how accurate my
predictions are and see where my data
set may be failing just through the web
UI that's kind of just given to me yeah
you know maybe not failing so much is
you know just needing a little more data
really nice visuals on that actually you
can pick a given label and you can see
sort of color-coded little thumbnails
things like the false positives the the
false negatives the true positives etc
so you can just sort of scan for a given
category again where the categories or
things like sheltered scarps and and see
how well it's doing yeah one other thing
that you remind me about amy is the UI
provides what's called a confusion
matrix which shows you for each of your
labels what percentage of your photos
were correctly identified as that label
so in my case i could see that maybe 80%
of my cumulus clouds were being
correctly identified as cumulus but
maybe 20% of them were being
misclassified as cumulonimbus clouds so
then i could go back to my training data
and see where i need to add more images
and what images maybe aren't labeled
correctly any things that you learned
from working with the API that you feel
like you want to make sure you know when
people start to experiment that they
keep in mind how they approach it how
they use it one thing that is great to
remember that we already touched on is
that you can use the human labeling
service I haven't tried this out yet but
I'm really keen to try it out once I
have a data set that makes sense for it
so you haven't tried out the human
labeling piece amy was there anything
else that you thought you wanted to make
people aware of from your experience
yeah I'm the topic of labeling one other
thing we should mention is that auto ml
vision supports multi labeled data sets
so that means that you can have a set of
images that you've you've not given just
one classification label to but multiple
classification labels to so that's a
really nice feature suite another thing
to mention is that once you've trained
your model it's instantly ready in
production to handle traffic so it's
available for serving right away on
Google cloud platforms so you don't have
to worry about provisioning any of this
infrastructure on your own and it will
also scale to zero so it's ready to
handle lots and lots of prediction
requests if you're not getting any it'll
scale down to zero that's a really good
point to make sweet I was gonna ask the
question so if people are listening to
this in their life this sounds amazing I
want to play with this now where should
they go what can they do to start
playing with this thing good question
mark so well in the show notes we'll put
a link to a form that you can fill out
to get whitelisted and we were told that
the response to that
should be very quick we'll also provide
a link to the product page and there's a
little intro video that's launching
today to give you an overview of the
product so we'll link to that in the
show notes as well so people do need to
be white listed in order to access it as
a starting point yet during the Alpha
that's correct but again we were told
that the response would be very quick
great well anything else that you wanted
to share with those listening about Auto
ml nothing for me I think we covered it
all I think comes to mind we're very
excited about it it's a super useful and
really easy to use great excellent for
people to try it out and have any
feedback we'd love to hear what you
think so we'll have our Twitter handles
in the show notes it's a great way to
give us feedback on the product and
we'll make sure it gets back to the
product team are either of you speaking
about Auto ml anytime soon people come
find you if you're local to the Seattle
area and you're thinking to go to
conference called AI next con I will be
having a talk about Auto ml the day
after we expect this podcast to come out
so please look me up and say hi if
you're there I'm gonna be speaking about
Auto ml at dev fest Minneapolis on
February 10th so if you're gonna be at
that event if you feel like braving the
cold to come it's a great event I've
been the past two years come and say hi
and learn more about Auto ml great well
thank you both again for joining us and
telling us about Cloud automail vision
and I hope you guys have a good rest of
your day thanks for having us thank you
see ya okay well that was great thanks
Amy and Sarah we appreciate the overview
of Auto ml yeah that's really cool tech
especially as someone who is definitely
not in the machine learning spectrum
being able to use these kind of tools to
basically train and influence how models
work without having to do all that
research is really really impressive
agreed it's where things are going so
it's nice to see where it is with cloud
vision and then to think about where
it's gonna be going from there so
question of the week
yeah so question of this week is if I'm
a student or say I work for an academic
institution such as a university and I
want to be able to use Google cloud
platform but ideally I'll pay for it um
how do I go about getting some credits
to a label me to basically learn how to
use Google cloud platform so we have
education grants and we're providing the
link of course is always on our blog
post and so students and faculties can
apply at this link and actually
I think it's more specifically for
faculty to apply then they can give
access for students but apparently we
have two different approaches for those
who are in the u.s. versus those who are
international and they provide the
eligibility on the site you know they're
usually looking for universities that
originally accredited or have some level
of accreditation for those specifically
teaching computer science or something
related so we'll definitely provide that
information and you can apply you can
get credits you can play around with
this to do research in at an academic
level yeah I'm just having a look last
time I looked at this there was an
international support so this is
actually really cool there's a list of
looks like about 30 odd different
countries that are available but if you
are a country or an institution that is
not part of the countries that are
currently listed please do Express
interest that is something that we look
at so that we can look to expand the
program future great well mark are you
going to be anywhere in the next few
weeks or next couple months really all
I'm doing right now is preparing for
Game Developers Conference in March so
everything is focused towards that how
about yourself you're going anywhere I
am I'm gonna be in London at the end of
the month speaking at AI Congress I was
looking forward to that yeah awesome
all right well Melanie thank you very
much for joining me for yet another
episode of the podcast episode two of
the 2018 excellent and
we'll see you all next week see you next
week
you